atresia duodenal es un defecto de
nacimiento en el que la primera parte
del intestino delgado del bebé llamado
duodeno está bloqueada
ubicado entre el estómago y el intestino
grueso
el intestino delgado absorbe los
nutrientes de los alimentos
el intestino delgado tiene tres partes
el duodeno
el yeyuno
y el íleon
el duodeno se forma durante la sexta
semana de embarazo
aquí se puede observar el tubo que se
convertirá en el sistema digestivo el
duodeno crece justo por debajo del
estómago en desarrollo
las células dentro del duodeno crecen
tan rápido que el tubo se bloquea por un
breve momento
luego como parte del desarrollo normal
las células que bloquean el interior del
duodeno desaparecen Hasta que el
intestino en desarrollo se abre
nuevamente
cerca de la décima semana de embarazo
por razones desconocidas es posible que
la pared externa del duodeno no haya
crecido adecuadamente además es posible
que las células que bloqueen el interior
del duodeno no hayan desaparecido
En consecuencia se forma un defecto
llamado atresia duodenal en el que una
parte del duodeno se bloquea en una o
más formas
puede ser bloqueado por una red de
tejido que recubre el interior
o es posible que haya una ausencia total
de una parte del duodeno
Por último el duodeno puede haberse
estrechado
cualquiera de Estos tipos de atresia
evitan que el bebé absorba los
nutrientes de la leche debido a que el
líquido no puede atravesar el duodeno
la atresia duodenal no pone en peligro
la vida de inmediato pero requerirá de
una operación a los pocos días del
nacimiento para reparar el dúo de no
bloqueado
antes de la operación un tubo de succión
ong insertado de inmediato después del
nacimiento a través de la nariz o de la
boca quitará el exceso de líquido y aire
del estómago se le darán anestesia
general al bebé para que duerma durante
toda la operación
se le insertará un tubo respiratorio por
la nariz o boca y en la tráquea para
ayudar al bebé a respirar durante la
operación
por lo general el cirujano hace una
incisión debajo de las costillas sobre
el lado derecho luego hallará
cuidadosamente la atresia o partes
estrechada y bloqueada del duodeno del
bebé
se realizarán dos incisiones en el
duodeno por encima y por debajo de la
atresia
el cirujano utilizará suturas para
conectar las dos aberturas
de esta manera evitará la atresia
finalmente el cirujano cerrará la
incisión de la piel con suturas solubles
o tiras de sutura cutánea
después de la operación se llevará al
bebé a la unidad de Cuidado intensivo
neonatal para ser monitoreado
se le administrará analgésicos
el bebé puede continuar recibiendo
antibióticos mediante vía intravenosa el
bebé será dado de alta del hospital
dentro de dos a cuatro semanas cuando el
sistema digestivo funcione normalmente